hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica I've done
some work I think you'll be very
impressed with what I've accomplished
here don't mind the scary noises outside
of my new home that is the sounds of
death actually let's go take a look at
what the son - oh god oh god oh that was
that my hand
I better open my head so I restarted my
new game with the new update and
actually there was another update that
happened just earlier either this week
or today but I've managed to get back
pretty much where I was before in a new
location that's not in the kelp forest
but that's actually a bit farther oh my
god ah okay I saw something and I saw
something there all right you guys you
guys know I'm talking about her hey
there was something there okay so
basically I've managed to get back a bow
where I am before except that now I have
my own base and I'm starting to expand
it right about now I've also developed
my own fabricator and my new locker by
the way my name is bubble bud case you
guys didn't know that's the new runner
of this channel bubble bud
but with its Locker I should be able to
do exactly what I need to do with
whatever I need to do it so now we just
have to wait until night stops being
night and I stopped seeing things out of
the Oh what are you Oh God
Oh what are you Oh what is that
Oh why's its mouth Gloria hi I shouldn't
say hi to this guy oh god I doesn't look
too terrifying
hi oh oh you running away from
Okita oh okay you have a lot of teeth oh
you're probably bad oh you're probably
bad hello that's like you Oh God well
that's terrifying
you said no oh God Oh
oh okay well that's one hell of a way to
start off this episode all right that's
uh I almost died yeah
something happens every day in the
adventurous life of mr. McGuire so let
me just let me uh we just find my balls
wherever I put them and get back to work
as I camp out and wait for day to come o
day cannot come soon enough okay I don't
know if I have enough oh I do have
enough for a window okay so good so now
I can look out upon the ocean see death
as it approaches yeah okay so now hahaha
what I need oh hi buddy
I'm gonna call you strewed abaga Oh
strudy you know he Oh God that was the
scariest thing ever Hey what are you
doing
strudy heist Rudy come back here you're
gonna be my new roommate
okay so they changed a lot of things in
this new update they added some
graphical additions oh man
huh it's got such a Wiggly body
strudy ah come on screwed don't be like
that
I'll come play with you later the only
thing that I don't have is my uh my see
vehicle fabric hooray well you know the
thing you know I'm talking about the UH
what was it called
I have no yeah the deployed the mobile
vehicle Bay I don't have that because
they don't have any lubricant or a Power
Cell so I don't know if I should go for
that next I might do that in a later
episode but for now there's been some
things that have changed about the game
god damn he is not going away the
central Dark Matter reactor will reach a
supercritical state I have a tee - huh
hang on Karen please let's talk about
this God don't be like that
Oh Karen Karen oh hello
Oh ain't that pretty hooray Margot
Blair's back haha also I don't remember
there being a planet over there either
that's a planet or a really big moon so
nothing that's radii shotgun just go a
little under here now oh man so he took
a nice radiation bath that was awfully
lovely but there were some different
changes that were made they changed some
of the day I think they added new sea
creatures they ended up by the way like
my shirt hey I'm a gamer I like video
games head MIT okay so the next thing
that I'm gonna be doing is I'm gonna be
gathering up a few resources to try to
build a mobile vehicle Bay and then I'm
gonna try to conquer the resources next
to Siri to do that but first I'm gonna
show you my awesome base here see here's
a story when I was building this it was
pitch black cuz it was middle of night
and I thought that I was at the bottom
of the ocean so when I was building this
here I was under the impression that I
was you know not gonna lead my base off
into a precipice of death that I could
not support so this is about as big as
it's gonna get unless I'm able to build
down to the ocean floor
anyway let's actually try to breathe a
little bit and I also have this thing
called a scanner I don't exactly know
what it does or what its purpose is but
I can't seem to pick up the seamoth
fragments anymore and I think I realized
that the seamoth is actually like a
fellow god that guys just roll in that
area
strudy strudy why you gotta be like that
strewed ah come on strewed that's his
name's Trudi pie oh god oh god oh did
you just poop oh oh god stop pooping I
don't think he's pooping but I'm
strudy come on we gotta be roommates
about this but that was it propulsion
cannon fragment whoa that's cool that's
really cool I hope strudy isn't claw
down my neck hi screw D okay so me and
strudy you're gonna be chillin but um so
with the encyclopedia DD added from that
there's been a few other oh god oh god
it's another one of them why did I build
my base in the middle of Hell an oceanic
hell I don't know because I'm an idiot
okay so what I need to do is one I need
to tidy up this place a little bit more
if I can build boring windows there'd be
onsen I don't know if I yeah I don't
have enough dang it but maybe I could
make enough hello glass please I need to
get more quarts last time I had plenty
of quarts but I didn't know what to do
with it now that I'm actually playing
the game slightly correctly I need more
of air god that guy that guy's gonna
gulp me down in one glove okay but I
think I need creepvine and that's the
only thing I need to be able to make a
first aid kit don't even think about it
that's trude's your fluids
it's trude's and flutes and don't come
near me either one of you
upside margins Karen I'm gonna get this
eventually parameter what Bradham okay
tonight I got that I think I could make
lubricant out of this oh hello what are
you hey where'd you go what the hell
what an evasive dude oh never mind it
was right there okay no time for that
but I'm pretty sure that I can make
lubricant out of these i'm fearly
thornton 40 seconds oh shut up Karen
living with you has been the biggest
toll on my existence I can't believe I
have to share a life under the sea with
you
this marriages Anya also I have solar
panels on my thing by the way that means
that I can get power and for some reason
you can make gold turn into more power
somehow for stayed get bleach I oh I got
bleach in my bubble butt hip okay Ariel
okay so now that we got that the little
of ID boy than one hood look oh god I
should probably use more than one
another encounter with screws or flutes
it's gonna end up to be the worse of me
or the death of me probably the death of
me and that's gonna be worse for me okay
so can I make any lubricant yes I can
thank you very much I needed lubed for
something but now what you're thinking
of I'm alone under this ocean there's
nothing going on in that department oh
boy a big old tub Lube uh man I wonder
what job I had outside of going into the
ocean that I know how to make lube on
demand out of whatever materials is
that's my one superpower the ability to
make Lube not really super powers more
like a job but hey whatever don't
question me okay so now that I have the
lube I should be able to make something
else once again those those sounds don't
seem good Oh oh boy oh yeah I want that
oh I want that I knew I carried around
of freaking acid mushrooms for no
particular reason
oh that sounded oh oh oh this is cool oh
that's so cool
Oh oh good how do it how do I anyway Wow
look at me I don't know if I'm going any
faster but goddamn and I can scan this
so what these do when I scan these to
give me more recipes I'm I mean you guys
piece that together I'm the idiot I have
to say it out loud modification station
interesting how do I wait I'm not it's
not oh it is
is it I don't know maybe yeah it is yeah
it is okay so I got a fine is that a
good sound or a bad sound
how would I know seamoth fragment so if
I can get enough of the sea mouth
warning thirty seconds of oxygen
remaining shut up oh we got quiet okay
so I need five of the FIH mouth so if I
can only find other words I tell you
when I was trying to get back to where I
was before I was attacked by more things
than I've ever been attacked in my
original game they must have made it far
more deadly see look at that
that planet ass planet I feel like I
would have noticed that before
I mean I'm unobservant in certain
circles well I feel like I would have
noticed a planet popping up out of
nowhere so anyway that's that so I got
to find more of these doodads and that's
actually cool it shows like a
topographical map of where I'm going not
too shabby if I do say so myself I mean
I know I can't exactly claim any credit
for making the things the magical
wonderful creations that I have because
it's all done by a fabricator and not
even remotely done by me but I want to
take credit for it anyway cuz that's
just how I roll Oh hot damn three out of
five so if I can make a sea mouth that's
good right I guess I don't know cuz if I
can make the seamoth than I should be
able to travel even farther and have
like a mobile base going on oh yeah I'm
Way faster with this maybe down here I
can explore a little whoa this is
probably how does it take
oh they gonna give me no more Oh who's
the winner now
I shouldn't get so cocky I know that I
shouldn't be so cocky but it's not often
that I win at anything in this game oh
that's a good right to the service Oh
Free Willy okay yeah yeah and eventually
once I get my lead line suit I will go
back and see if I can explore and
scrounge out some better materials up
and who T wants it the shipping to do
blue t the blue t ship I just hope that
Trudy and Flutie don't mess with my
stuff while I'm gone oh they're
pranksters actually what I noticed is
that I don't exactly have an
identification
what
I shouldn't go down here wait hang hang
on let's say before I do any of the oh
oh go go god oh god I shouldn't be here
lava rocks yeah it's bad that's bad
oh wow look at oh I'm going I'm going
I'm gonna stake oh oh this was a mistake
hahaha I should be why do I run face
first into danger that's what I want to
that's what I want to whoa
hmm I don't know it was cool I guess I'm
such a badass I just go straight into
the dangerous moments and I doubt that
I'm gonna be able to find my way home
after this ah you know when they said
they updated the whole environment I
didn't know exactly what they were
talking about but this does seem like a
lot more variety around here I mean even
this kelp forest the area and I have no
idea where my home is whoa what oh I
thought that was like the the bottom
part of a whale is just a coral - oh man
so when this thing is out of energy does
it just die forever and I have to make a
new owner is it like just a recharge
basis thing inventory full gosh darn it
okay this is four out of five Oh Karen
you know I used to care that you were
appreciative of my health and survival
but frankly I had about enough of it I'm
a cranky old man we've been stuck
underwater for years years I can't do it
anymore
anyway that's right I gotta get
back and I got to drop off some stuff
because I picked up way too much crap
but if I can just find one more seamoth
fragment that would mean that I would be
able to do something with something
where the hell am I see there's so many
nooks and crannies but I mean before it
was a little more difficult because
everything kind of did look the same but
I imagine there's like an item called a
beacon that I could make that would
probably give an idea of where my bases
because in relation to that one I know
it's somewhere over here whoa oh oh it's
so pretty
oh it's so pretty
it almost makes me entirely forget that
the ocean is entirely comprised of fish
poop Oh modification station okay I
think I only needed three of this one
and it all uh-oh
it's getting dark I'm gonna go home now
Oh wowie Zowie oh wow oh it's such a
rapid change to death just instantly
darkness and death thanks I'm just gonna
be holding my here's my thing don't its
little weird I know but don't mind it
okay so what I need to do is I need to
make more glass glass is pretty much the
first thing that I need and for most out
of all the materials because I want to
make more windows that's just for vanity
sake it doesn't really do anything for
me but it is cool right guys I'm cool
right I need water
bleach I thought I had bleach stereo
blodge pepper and welder
my wasting my power with the thing okay
cap good blue ink okay so we're doing
pretty okay so welcome back everyone to
subnautica I'm gonna keep playing this
game in the next episode I'm gonna make
sure that I get the seamoth fragment
last piece before I start the episode
and that way you guys will know exactly
what we're gonna be doing so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye
on dancing alone looks so sad